this is a production of cornell
university
so thank you so much for inviting me
here to talk to you guys today um
and it's been a great visit so far it's
really nice to be able to go places in
person again
so
i'm going to talk to you today um
about some of the work that mike
mentioned so this we're looking at sugar
accumulation and sorghum and what
structural variation has been doing in
that process
so
also like mike mentioned i i am broadly
um trained as an evolutionary biologist
population geneticist and what i'm
really interested in sort of at the
heart of everything is just how do
populations diversify and particularly
what goes on at the genome level
that lets these things adapt to
different places or take on a lot of
phenotypic differences
and if these things are complex if these
kinds of changes are complex
then what does that look like at the
genetic level and how can we find it
and so i haven't always worked in
sorghum i've worked in all kinds of
weird stuff and even adding to the weird
list of things i've worked on in the
past i've now got mosquito things going
on and hummingbird things so
uh my steve president used to call me
species agnostic which is a pretty good
description
um but i've been doing a lot of work in
sorghum and it's actually a really great
model for sort of understanding this
process of diversification so sorghum is
really um phenotypically
diverse and we have all these different
types and i'll tell you a bit about that
in a second so
i'm going to sort of give you sort of a
case study here of some a trait that we
are interested in and how we started
looking at a particular gene family
because of the what we found going on
with these faiths
so broadly what i'll talk about today
i'll give you guys a bit of a overview
of the history of sorghum and its
diversification and what the different
types are
and some of our past work where we
looked at sort of global patterns of
diversity um i started finding things
going on in metal transport
and then i want to spend more of the
talk talking a bit about an actual
functional study looking at one one gene
in particular that was of interest and
it's probably the one molecular biology
thing i have to talk about um
and then looking a little bit we looked
a little bit at some expression and
stuff as well
so to give you guys um an overview of
sorghum so sorghum was originally
domesticated in africa um kind of around
where president-day sudan is and there's
some debate about whether or not there's
a second origin
i feel like i'm going to hit the wrong
button for laser pointer
and then
i'll give up there we go um a second
origin over here but we know for sure
there was one
in this area
and then after that it starts spreading
east and west and
during this time we started to get what
are the different races of sorghum so
they take on sort of phenotypically
distinct traits you can see here where
there's more humidity you have these
open panticles
here where it's dryer you get very sort
of tight tight panicles with lots of
seeds there's also a lot of things going
on with how they actually adapt to the
climate and soils in these regions as
well
so
even more of this goes on as these
spread actually away from africa and
into the middle east it's sort of china
so then actually they they start coming
back to these same dura types they
spread east they then move back into
africa after they've already diverged a
bit while they've been off the continent
and then finally you see things start to
move south and you get this cafe race um
and this is a big change because again
you're going from tropical to actually
temporary latitudes with different day
lengths
so
during all of this time you've got a lot
of interesting adaptations going on so
sorghum is of interest to people um in
agriculture because it's you know it's
very photosynthetically efficient it's
drought tolerant you have it during its
spread it becomes adapted to all these
different types of regions what you
can't see here is you're also adapting
to different elevations you're adapting
to different moisture levels or adapting
different soil types so we know there's
got to be a lot of physiological and
morphological changes going on
and so it does lead to the question
what's the genetic basis of that
and then on top of that historical sort
of diversification we've got things that
are going on in the present day so
sorghum has been now cultivated for
these diverse purposes where you can
have types that you grow just for the
grain production they mature more
quickly they're shorter they obviously
put on a lot of grain
um the types i'll talk about today which
are these sweet varieties they get a lot
taller
they do put on grain but they put on
less grain and the main thing is they
accumulate actually a lot of sugar in
their stock so you can press them like
sugar cane and that's where we get
things like sorghum syrup and sorghum
molasses
and then you've got these giant biomass
types that never flower in temperate
zones they just grow indefinitely here's
the top of a person
this is one of steve's old pictures i
think this might actually be someone
from cornell who's in this picture but
just to give you some perspective of how
big these things get
yes this is a
um so i want to tell you a little bit
more about sweet sorghum as well so it's
sort of specific history since that's
what we're going to be
talking about today so sweet sorghum has
actually also started to be cultivated
pretty early so even in the early
domestication of sorghum um people
people are interested in actually
getting sort of that chewing cane sweet
varieties out of it and so there's
evidence for this going on you know as
early as 200 a.d in that same region of
original domestication
and then just light grains so we're
going to the sweet sorghum varieties
sort of spread along the trade routes
they go east and west and south and
there seems to be um there's now it's
kind of more evidence that actually you
have multiple origins of sweet sorghum
so each of those places that it ends up
some people might have started
cultivating sweet sorghum from grain um
in those places so that's kind of a
parallel evolution of that type
um
and so as i mentioned these what's
phenotypically distinct about them is
their height um the smaller grain heads
and the fact that they accumulate all
these sugars in the salt
and then not necessarily key to the
stock but sort of anecdotally
interesting um sweet sorghum is actually
the first type of sorghum brought
commercially
to the u.s um and it was for it's
because it's much less labor intensive
um and cane so it was brought over by
abolitionists who thought it would be an
alternative to sugarcane which required
slaves
and then now we're interested in it um
as also a possible biofuel source
because you can't actually use the
sugars for biofuel
so if we look at just sort of the
genome-wide genetic differences of
sorghum
what we see is that their genetic
differentiation reflects their history
not necessarily these present day types
so these are
several different studies so this is
using um
i want to say about 200 000 snip markers
we've got about a thousand genotypes and
what you can see with the clusters is
that they very much genetically cluster
with where they are from um
this is a set of only bioenergy types
and they again they very much cluster by
location here's a bunch of ethiopian
ones and by that historic race so this
is the cafe varieties the southern
varieties here's the original bicolors
and the guineas which are the western
sorghum
and then more recently
we had a resequencing panel of about 320
accessions we actually
had enough data to do the structural
variation analysis so we looked
specifically at deletions
and we can see that even in that
different type of mutations these bigger
higher impact deletions you still see
the same sort of clustering
the font here is way too small for you
but it's again going by location and
race is how things are dividing
so you can't just sort of look at the
broad patterns of genetic diversity and
compare you know the sweets stall the
grains and see what the genetic
difference is what you actually see is
there's sort of historical difference
but there has been a lot of prior work
done um
looking for what the genetic control is
of sweetness and so one of the key
traits that people are able to isolate
is actually stem juiciness so this this
water content of the stall
so here on the end these are these are
non-sweet varieties they have what's
called a pipi stem
and then here in the middle we've got
juicy varieties and you can see when you
dry them out they look even more
distinct and this is actually a single
genetic locus that controls this it's
called the dry locus it was originally
sort of characterized in 1916 but then
no one had really looked at the
molecular gene underlying it until um
2018
so more than 100 years later but they
did find that this gene actually
controls this transcription factor that
regulates cell wall biosynthesis um and
what goes on is the sweet sorghums have
a loss of function deletion and so what
they get is much less stable cell walls
as well as some other changes so it
changes the thickness um and it allows
you actually to accumulate all this
water and also so you don't have these
sort of strong structures even when you
dry out
but even though that locus explains
where your stem juiciness it's not
explaining
all of the sugar accumulation in fact
this right here is btx 623 which is
classified as a grain sorghum and it's
actually the current reference genome
for sorghum so
it can accumulate some sugars but it
does not accumulate nearly the amount of
the types that we see sort of pressed
for press for the actual syrups or
sugars um
so
this has a juicy salt but it can it's
not actually all that sweet some other
studies have tried looking more just
sugar accumulation in particular um with
with qtl studies with gus um with sort
of targeted candidate gene sequencing of
things that we know transport sugar or
things that we know synthesize sugar
and what's always been the case is you
can
you can find expression differences in
the candidate gene in one line the same
thing is not going on in another same
with the qtl one cross has this big qtl
in a particular region next cross you
look at it's not the same thing
um
and
one of the sort of tricky bits about
this again is like you know we probably
have this parallel origin of sweetness
there's maybe not one thing because it
might have happened sort of multiple
times in those different locations
the other really tricky thing is that
there's actually a lot of confounding
from the maturity patterns so the sweet
sorghums take longer to develop in
general than the grain type sorghums and
so they're also sort of accumulating
sugar as they develop and so a lot of
times when you sort of look for
differences what you get are qtl that
overlapped the maturity genes
so
well sort of all of the
all of the interest sort of from an
agronomic perspective in the sugar trait
and then kind of all these still
unknowns about what was the mechanism of
it we decided to actually generate a
reference genome specifically for sweet
sorghum um because one thing that we
thought was well there might actually be
sort of structural variation going on
that would control this trait and that's
not something you would see by just
taking short reads and aligning them to
the reference genome
so while i was in steve's lab at clemson
as a postdoc we generated a de novo
assembly for the rio genome um so rio is
this sort of historically
important sweet line that's been around
for a while
and
once we assembled it what we found was
actually rio and vtx 623 are quite
similar in terms of their overall size
structure
and gene content
and in fact
this
circle is believe it or not a venn
diagram sort of showing so when you look
at this in maze right if you're if
you're trying to show the amount of
routine content overlap you get you know
like a circle here a circle here is
maybe like 25 or 50 shared here there's
98 of the genes are shared between the
two lines you may be um have a few genes
sort of unique to each
one percent or less than one percent of
the genes actually seem unique to the
particular lines
now there's been a more recent study um
in the last year from mma's group in
australia where they actually did look
um as more of a sorghum pan genome so
they included more to more diverse lines
and about 13 different sorghum lines and
looked at this
and it puts it a bit into perspective
for us so
what they find is they're only about 36
percent of the genes are poor
and then they have about 63 or what they
call shell so it's not in all the lines
but it's in more than one
and then a very small percent is
actually unique to just a particular
single line
and
we have rio here in btx 623 so
what we know once we now we see this and
we see this is that what btx 623 and rio
are sharing is a lot of the shell genes
as well as a lot of the core genes so
they have genes that they share with
each other that other sorghum lines
might not have um but that they do also
share
and so we do go in and look at well they
might not have that many differences but
they still got a few hundred and so what
were what were those what genes does rio
have that btx 623 doesn't and vice versa
and is that something to do with the
sugar phenotype
we actually initially thought we had
something really interesting so we we
saw that a bunch of genes in this sweet
transporter family were actually missing
in rio so missing in the sweet sorghum
um
or not expressed at all so they actually
had enough of a mutation to be sort of
completely possibly non-functional
anymore
um and so we knew that these these
transporters moved sugar sort of out of
stocks out of leaves and so we thought
well maybe if you don't have these extra
transporters you just keep the sugars
into your stock and that's one of the
ways you can accumulate it
but this um hypothesis sort of blew up
once we once we got a lot more um
sorghum lines we actually sort of did
that we did that structural variation
analysis and we tried to see okay are
all these same things deleted if we look
across a lot of different lines
and what we found is that no it looks
really random so
here i've just sort of got broad
categories these are non-sugar
accumulating tall lines just sort of a
narrow thing of grain lines
here's the sweet um your purple
and not purple are showing you where
there's beans or not um in certain
families and all i really want you to
take away from this figure is that it's
random there's obviously not any sort of
pattern here associated with how things
are grouped on the bottom so in other
words even though rio had those sugar
transporters deleted
if you look in other lines some sweet
lines haven't deleted some sweet lines
don't some of them have other things
deleted that rio has so it really just
looks pretty polymorphic
so then we stepped back um and wanted to
think well okay if it's not if it's not
those things we already knew had to do
with sugar let's look at what's sort of
broadly
going on in terms of variation in gene
content in the two genomes and maybe
that's actually where we should be more
interested
so we looked at um
what types of genes tended to have
presence abstinence variation in the two
lines
and then
also which types of genes tended to have
really really high impact non-synonymous
mutations so things that really look
like they change function
and what we see um is that in both cases
your most significant categories are
actually always related to disease
resistance and that's not that
surprising that's been seen in a lot of
other plants and it makes sense why
that's something that you would have a
lot of variation in gene content in
but
what one of these things that's always
significant although never the most
significant was metal ion binding or
metal ion transport
and so we we kept seeing it and actually
particularly in your highlight divergent
mutation category you see a lot of the
um metal transporters coming up here and
so it started to make us think well
maybe that's actually something because
that was a little less expected than the
disease resistance genes
and so we also did a differential
expression study um
in the in the two lines to see if we
could see which in that sense what
things were going on and
i'm going to go through this a little
bit quickly because i want to get to
other stuff but the general idea is that
we have pr22 which was actually a
recombinant in red line from a rio by
btx cross
and so what we did was we picked the one
offspring from that cross
that looked the most like rio in terms
of its maturity um and you know it's all
of its growth patterns but just did not
accumulate sugar so we're trying to just
isolate that one difference and then we
sort of looked at what the expression
differences were between them
and then we also took the genes that
were expressed differently and thought
about which ones actually
are coming from a place in that real
that had the rio parent allele versus
the btx allele and so we're most
interested in genes that are very
differentially expressed between the two
and come from the non-sweet allele so
that would actually be the mutation
within that gene that could be affecting
the expression
and so what we saw was in general when
we compare the patterns of expression um
one of our most significant groups here
is um again
sort of
metal membrane transport um and what's
noticeable at this group and probably
pretty hard to see from far away this is
actually one of our only categories
where it's more enriched for deans that
have the btx background than it is for
teens that had the sweet background
and just to sort of emphasize why
why that matter to us is if you're very
differentially expressed between the two
but you have the speed allele then it
seems like you're just something that's
responding
to sugar not necessarily something
that's causing the sugar to accumulate
differently because one of the things we
know about sugar is that
once you're getting sweeter you're
actually signaling a lot of other
pathways to change so it's hard to
differentiate so we're not doing a real
eqtl study here because we've got one
thing we're just sort of doing a very
poor man's qtl
we've got one line and we're just
thinking about the genetic background in
it
and then we specifically we went back to
our genes that we knew had really high
impact mutations and we tried to overlay
that data with what was actually um very
differentially expressed between the two
and so we're looking for things that
have the predicted functional effect
mutations and look like they're
expressed differently when you have the
genes on the two different genetic
backgrounds
and we get um a handful of things that
are actually known not just metal
transporters but actually really known
to be in the iron transport
pathway
so we have um some zip genes
we've got a ysl gene um and then we also
got these bhla transcription factors um
which are known now there's a big family
but the one of the one of the main
regulators of iron transport one of
these transmission factors is actually a
bhlh
type transmission factor
and then kind of the the final past
study i want to quickly tell you about
so um
i had mentioned that we started looking
at a broader panel of about 300 or 400
individuals and we had done resequencing
at about a 50x step so that we could
look at structural variation um
particularly deletions it's pretty hard
to look at structural variation with
short read data even with a lot of it
um but what we saw when we looked at
genes that had
a lot of actually large deletions so 50
base pairs or bigger
we saw that
if you isolate them down to the
deletions that seem like they're
happening in a specific population or a
specific group
um then also you see metal transporters
um very much enriched in that group so
there's no way you guys can read this
but here um the colors here are sort of
showing you
for the deletions which ones are are
happening and sort of the different
groups so the colors or your different
populations
here we've actually got some gene ids um
the
only thing you can really take from this
is that the place where we actually see
the metal transporters seem like they
have the most deletions is in the red
group and the red group
is um
specifically over here in ethiopia and
it seems to be the ethiopian highland
sorghum so it's a it's a particular
group of them
so not necessarily related to sweetness
in that case but still showing something
about sort of population adaptation and
diversification in sorghum
so
i do want to take a second here you know
so i showed you these sort of very short
quick snippets of a bunch of different
studies we've done over the years
and one thing you might have noticed
from them is that
we see metal transporters as significant
but it's never the most significant
thing and there's a lot of other stuff
there and so you might ask the question
well why did you guys zero in on this
metal transport thing it's certainly not
the not the only thing there's all kinds
of disease resistance um and other types
of genes
and you know one
one reason was just because it was it
was one of those categories that it just
kept recurring kind of no matter what
study we were doing and we were never
really looking for them we kept seeing
something related to them
but then the other reason comes from
this um study that i'm about to show you
next
so while i was doing the work on the rio
genome there was a graduate student in
st president's lab who is looking at
genomic association for sort of
bioenergy related traits
and one of the traits he was looking at
was stem sugar content
and he found a very significant geos hit
sort of here on chromosome 4
and then he redid the study and he found
it
again
and what was under that gwas was
actually
this particular vacuole or iron
transporter or something that was
annotated as that
and when we first saw that we just
didn't really know why that would be
coming up for this trait but it was it
kept being the most significant thing
that we were seeing
um and so if we look a little more
closely at the haplotype what we see is
there's a really strong haplotype
structure where if you're sweet
you have this you almost you must always
have all the blue alleles and if you're
yellow you've got this and there's a
very significant sort of grouping and
like how much carbohydrate content you
have depending on what haplotype you
have
so the region itself you know it's cus
it had four genes um
and only one had the non-synonymous
mutation and it was this bit or this
vacuolar iron transporter
so it was kind of a candidate but it
wasn't a great one because the
non-mutation was actually not in the
functional domain it was in some domain
of the protein we didn't really know
what it was for
um it was originally annotated as nodule
and like and sorghum doesn't have
nodules so we really didn't know what to
make about that
the public expression data it looked
really low so it just a lot of things
made it look like maybe this wasn't
actually a real gene it might be a
pseudo gene
um and then it didn't overlap with any
of the qtls were previously identified
for this trait
but then so
a new version of the reference genome
came out and i created the sort of rio
reference genome and when we looked at
this region again
it actually started to look more
interesting because what we could see
now was that what you had um was a
tandem duplication in the vacuolar iron
transporters that only happens in
sorghum
so everybody else has this one copy
sorghum has a second copy here's where
our dos candidate gene was it's in that
sorghum specific copy
and then what was additionally really
interesting is when we looked at the rio
assembly um
we actually saw that there was there was
a lot of difference so you had a lot of
non-synonymous high impact mutations in
this gene and actually the rio gene was
much bigger so the the original
reference genome the btx gene looked
like it was truncated compared to rio so
actually it looked more like a real gene
when we looked in the rio genome
and so we had a collaborator at penn
state who actually helped us with the
molecular characterization so we could
actually see whether or not this really
transports iron and whether or not
there's a difference in what the sweet
and non-sweet alleles are doing
and
i have you guys probably understand this
better than i do um but
so
what they did was they had a yeast
strain that was iron sensitive so the
the transporter had been knocked out in
it and they transformed it with an empty
vector um the arabidopsis bit that we
know exactly what it does and then the
two alleles so the sweet sorghum one and
the non-sweet sorghum bit and then you
grow it under different iron conditions
and the yeast can only survive if it's
able to transport iron because it's got
to be able to pump it out
and what we found was that only the
sweet allele for sorghum
shows that it can transport iron so only
the yeast with those alleles are able to
survive
so in your empty vector under control
conditions they grow but you add iron
and they don't grow at all
here's arabidopsis where it can grow in
both
the rio is the sweet allele it can also
grow in both but the btx you only see
growth in the control sort of no iron
conditions
um
oh and that's what i was thinking so
that was actually pretty interesting to
us because it suggested one of this
thing functions is how it was annotated
and there really is a functional
difference in the two types and so
there's there seems like it really could
be doing something um
important for these lines
but it's still not entirely clear what
it has to do with sugar accumulation per
se
so
we also wanted to sort of say well are
sweet sorghums
better at dealing with iron deficiency
or iron stress
than non-sweet sorghum so maybe they can
grow in lower iron conditions but still
make
make enough sort of sugar or
photosynthesize enough and maybe that's
one of the way they're getting sweeter
so what we did was a pretty
straightforward sort of pilot expression
study so we took a few about three
genotypes of each type um we grew them
in a hydroponic environment in different
iron conditions so we had control and
then iron deficient
um
and then we just wanted to look at
expression differences and we were
looking in pretty early stage in the
roots and one of the reasons is because
the evidence we did have for expression
of that bit one was potentially that it
was in the roots of seedlings the other
reason is because these sore gums get
really big and we didn't want to do that
in a grid safer
and so what we saw
[Music]
is that you get a lot more
differentially expressed genes
in your control versus low iron
conditions sort of for everybody so
these conditions of just your being an
iron deficient has a big effect on on
all of the genotypes
you still have a fair number of things
just differentially expressed between
the two types of things um even if
they're in the control conditions
but then you do get a really a handful
of really interesting things where
there's a significant interaction in
other words the way the different types
respond to the iron deficiency
is different
and just to give you guys a little bit
of background on how we actually did the
analysis we did a couple of things that
weren't entirely standard so one thing
is you know we have these multiple
genomes now so we actually tried mapping
our data back to both
and what we found was that in general
because everything we're growing here is
either biomass or sweet type they map
slightly better to the rio genome than
btx we get a higher percentage so we
went forward with those results
and we also we were interested in these
things you know we knew that that one
gene was a tandem duplication so we knew
we were interested in things where you
actually might get multiple mapping hits
so we used a program and a method where
you would retain those instead of
discarding or keeping one or the other
which is sort of your default method
and then we also
you know we're trying to look at type
here but it's type is just sort of a
genotype is a subset of type so we have
to look at difference between types and
control for differences
among the genotypes so rather than you
know your standard expression analysis
you treat each thing as a factor what we
actually did was treat your genotypes as
a random or random effect kind of like
how you would do a gus
and so what we found um and i'll start
with the middle bit so if you look for
your enriched kind of go terms and
you're in your low and normal iron
conditions you actually get a lot of the
things that you expect so there's things
related to iron transport and metal
metabolism and iron stress um and
there's there's a lot of known orthologs
of like in ramps zips copts so those
show up as significant in this
comparison but they are significant
regardless of what type you are so
that's just kind of your conserved
response to iron
the things that um show up kind of in
the
in your differences between types or
maybe less obviously sort of related to
the different um
to whether or not it's iron condition so
it seemed like different types of things
you actually see
sort of a lot of adp binding um
some
carbonate dehydrolase activity
uh things that look a lot of phosphatase
activity that's what's really going on
in here um and similarly over here when
you look at the things with significant
interactions it's more likely to overlap
with the categories for your differences
between types than necessarily for the
category here although there are a few
things um where you've got known sort of
iron transport genes and they actually
respond differently in the types
just to give you guys um a couple of
examples of some of the more significant
things we found
so
here is one gene it's a transmembrator
transmembrane transporter
it's not actually a known metal
transporter but it is in this nodulen
like transporter family
and what we actually see is that in your
non-sweet varieties when you expose them
to the low iron conditions it actually
gets slightly down regulated whereas in
your sweet varieties it becomes
upregulated so the the level of
expression actually shifts
whereas this um so here's here's this
bhlh transcription factor um that looks
like a homolog of these iro2 or iro3
sort of known regulators of iron
response and you can see it goes it's
very much upregulated
in both groups
it looks a little bit steeper in one but
i think that's actually sort of an
artifact of how much variation you have
um not necessarily that it's really so
this one this is really something that
shows up in both groups it's not
actually different between the types
and so this last analysis i want to talk
about one one of the things we notice so
the go enrichment didn't really tell us
that much but one of the things that we
noticed um
was that when we were looking at these
differences between types again it
seemed like a lot of time it was sort of
coming up in genes without a lot of
known homology or known function
compared with other species so i
actually wanted to explicitly look at
that and say
are differences between types more
likely to be happening in genes that
have a more recent evolutionary origin
in terms of their copy number so we did
an orthology analysis
across a bunch of representative species
and what we actually did was try to
determine for every gene and all the
genomes what was the origin of that
particular gene puppy and put it to a
branch on the sort of known tree among
all these organisms
and then we once we categorized all the
genes we saw well which ones of those
are the differentially expressed where
do they tend to be
on this tree
and what we find if you look at your
differential express genes again for all
individuals between your control and low
iron conditions
you don't actually see particular
enrichment at any one
node you kind of see it's more or less
distributed how you would expect just
based on how the genes are distributed
across that that tree that history of
the tree
you have a little bit of enrichment
maybe in grass-specific genes so genes
at the origin of duplication of all the
grasses
but that are shared among them
but if you look at your differentially
expressed genes
between just your genotypes it is very
much enriched in the sorghum specific or
sorghum polymorphic category
so it's really it's really going on it's
very enriched in this sort of new genes
and significantly depleted and things
that are shared among all angiosperms so
there's really conservations you just
don't see a lot of difference among
types or you see less than you would
expect by chance
it's not as obvious when you look at the
interaction genes but you do have some
enrichment here and kind of your unknown
ortholog genes but again what you really
see is it's never going on in those
really conserved genes so it seems like
there is something to do with sort of
having these new copies that lets you
get these differences between the types
so
i feel like i went through really fast
okay um so to start sort of summarizing
this so
we know that this sort of metal binding
and transport show a lot of variation
both in terms of their presence and
absence and their sequence divergence
when you look between just different
lines of sorghum
and we know that some of this seems like
it's connected between the difference
between the sweet and the non-sweet
types some of it also looks like it
might just be connected to kind of
global sort of adaptive differentiation
we don't really know what the direct
link is between the metal metabolism and
the sugar accumulation
we know that iron uptake is pretty
crucial for a lot of functions in plants
including photosynthesis so it could
just be
that if you're better at taking up iron
out of the soil you're just better at
producing sugar or whatever product
you're trying to make
but one alternative and what i tend to
think is more going on is that your
different copies of the different genes
might be getting specialized
functions and so it could either be
transporting things at different times
or possibly transporting molecules other
than other than iron
and we also saw that in the when you
compare the types in terms of expression
it looks like your newer gene copies um
are more likely to be linked to the sort
of type specific differences and the
older copies have maybe maintain their
original roles and the sort of stress
response that everyone has
and then we know at least in one case we
know that we have the sorghum specific
bacular iron transporter
where it has a loss of function and your
grain type it still has the function and
the sweet type what i didn't really get
into is that loss of function
it doesn't necessarily have to be loss
of ability to bind or transport iron it
could be loss of ability to get
localized to the vacuole because that
would also mean you can't pump things
out from where you're supposed to and
that would also let your yeast sort of
die from that so we still have some
questions about
what function is it actually losing
between those two types of things
so i flew through that and i'm sorry um
but i do i do want to stop um and thank
some people so
my former post doc kitty [ __ ] um he's
actually a graduate student from cornell
he did all of that sort of
global structural variation deletion
analysis um and he also set up the
rna-seq hydroponics study and did a lot
of that work as well
my student azita started in on the
rna-seq analysis and did a lot of that
differential expression
and then as well as my former
undergraduate student who had the
pleasure of doing a bunch of rna
extractions and taking care of plants in
the growth chamber
and then my current students
will and bailey have sort of been the
ones who have taken over some of this
work
and then i also want to specifically
thank some of my external collaborators
um so erin connelly at penn state is the
person who actually did those yeast
complementation studies um actually
probably her student brandon is the one
who really related them but they
happened in her lab
and then um jeremy schmutz from husband
output so
their group did a lot of the rio
sequencing um so we've worked a lot with
them on that
and then
during we're at cold spring harbor we
are currently working with um to do some
new genome assemblies specifically
related to the lines that we tested iron
in and also do the annotations for those
and get them into a database
um then of course i want to thank people
from my former lab at clemson
where i did a lot of the earlier work
related to the gus and first assembling
the rio genome
and with that i am happy to take any
questions
um
so the bit one and bit two are both
non-functional in the grain type sorry
so the um
the original vit copy is functional
but that second sorghum specific copy
in the grain sorghum it doesn't it looks
like it doesn't move iron out of the
vacuole and like i say it's not clear if
it's doing that because it can't move
iron or because it's not getting to the
vacuole to move it but it is definitely
truncated compared to the other allele
at that same gene copy in the sweet
sorghums
okay and you don't have a mutant of the
other
of the um
in the green circle
oh you mean we have like we have it put
in we haven't tried to transform with
the yeah
you do have a knockout
you know the one's not functional but
the other one is and i'm wondering if
you thought about knocking the other one
out
um
so we have thought about doing well we
first we thought about we actually put
on a proposal where one thing we want to
do is actually at least try it in
arabidopsis so try it implant rather
than in yeast um but no we don't
currently have a knocked out
copy and it's you know just just like
you say it's a little tricky because we
know everybody's got one functional copy
um
and so i think the the trick is trying
to get
see what see what just this extra copy
might be
doing you see diversification of an
expression in the
functional paralog in the sweet sorghum
so we've had a really hard time
you know one of the disappointing things
about the rna-seq experiment we did is
that we didn't actually see expression
of that of that particular gene at all
we've had a really hard time figuring
out when and where it is actually
expressed
and
it doesn't seem like it's at the same
time as that original
sort of gene copy so we don't don't
quite know where to find it we had sort
of seen in public data we saw this sort
of like
low bump of expression of it
you know possibly in those early root
seedlings but now now i think maybe that
wasn't real or maybe that was stuff that
should have mapped to the other one so
we're still trying to figure out where
it is
um
that's a good question i think
well i think one one thing that might
help with the new assemblies
particularly with the de novo
annotations is we might get a better
sense of
is it super polymorphic in terms of who
has what looks like a functional copy or
not same as some of those speech
transporters and that might make us
less interested in it if you don't sort
of see this you know all the others
conserving what looks like a functional
allele
in terms of sort of finding where it is
um
hopefully if people do a lot of
i see i so seek to do their annotations
you know the more the more data we get
from more time and tissues the more we
might look up on it i i do kind of have
a sense that maybe
you might need it under stress to
actually to actually see it
um
yeah the right stress and then the right
tissue
um
and then the right time yeah
so
yeah
so we see it we actually see it in all
the different ones and we try to in all
of our studies we try to include sweet
and non-sweet types that represented
multiple races so that it wasn't just
sort of all one versus the other but i
will say that what um
[Music]
you know you can you can kind of you can
breed the types from really any
different race but there's a
if you look at all of them there's a
tendency for the sweet types to sort of
come from the eastern
varieties or even that original bi-color
race whereas the bio energy types might
come more you might see also the western
sorghums
but you can see some of each and so we
we picked our panels to try and catch
that as best we could
i was curious if you had any idea if
like other
high sugar accumulating crops like
sugarcane itself if they exhibited any
sort of
you know weirdness and something to do
with metal
transport so i don't know if they
exhibit that but what i can tell you is
that in sugarcane they've looked more at
the you know these sort of targeted
expression studies and they've had a lot
more luck where you can really see
differences in known sucrose synthase
that you can relate to sugar
accumulation and that has very much been
selected for
in the domestication process
and so
i don't you know again i don't know
that's being a sort of hard genome you
know i don't i don't know what they've
looked at in terms of their whole genome
levels of variation
or radiation expression it'd be a good
question if they also show the metal
variation but they
they definitely show they show more
obvious variation and some known pathway
stuff
yes
uh you had a cool slide obviously thanks
for your talk by the way
uh
these genes that are new at different
levels of the phylogeny and then whether
they're differentially expressed between
iron or control
or between sweet and non-sweet
and uh
i wondered if can you sort of
extrapolate from that what what the
general
uh
like the general hypothesis around that
is like like if i were to go to some
other trades maybe tall and short or
maybe you know i don't know what just
uh
yeah different kinds of differential
expressions or instead of iron
deficiency
uh
yeah no shade
or something like this
what would i find like what's what's the
bigger framework that that explains what
you observed there yeah so um that's a
really good question so that you know i
would say sort of the the long-standing
evolutionary theory would suggest that
in stress and sort of stress or
environmental change related
things you might be more likely to see
diversification in newer gene copies
because what happens is you get through
some sort of
genome duplication event or some other
mutation you can get extra copies of
some of your genes and then a lot of
times you know plants will go back to
to diploid or they'll what they'll do is
they'll sort of lose extraneous copies
but while you have those extra copies
you've now got relaxed selection on them
so i've got the thing that works and now
i can do whatever i want to this stuff
and a lot of times it's going to be a
pseudo gene but that it really sort of
makes this substrate for this neo
functionalization
of genes and and so one of the one
theory is that one thing that would
drive sort of rapid you know
functionalization is disease pressure um
but another one would be something like
environmental stress and they've i think
i was telling kelly earlier you know
they've looked at
some kind of broad correlations between
you know these known angiosperm whole
duplication
events and retention of gene copies and
some triplications and some of these
other kind of known orders of plants and
they they seem to coincide with kind of
moments of global climate
shift
when you might need an environmental
change so i to my mind one thing is i
think you could have you could have
natural variations that are going on in
newer sorghum copies of something like a
metal gene or another
stress-related gene and they've been
selected to one keep extra copies so
these families are bigger
and then selected to be able to sort of
deal with slightly different
situations but i can imagine that in
human when we start selecting on things
in artificial
and artificial selection scenarios
that might be the same substrate we
inadvertently go to because you know
it's not going to kill the plant if
you're looking at these
newer copies or newer copies where you
have
a redundant copy that's still doing that
still doing the old job
right so you're not you don't want to
mess with like a developmental gene
but if you've got some of these extra
copies um and things that aren't
constitutively expressed
but expressed under stress that's a
place you're more likely to see
divergence
does that make sense or did i make it
more confusing
well uh
i i guess
i'm sure that makes sense so there's a
question of how smart i am to be able to
take your
your answer in but
you you see one phenomenon for iron
deficiency versus control and a
different phenomenon for sweet versus
non-sweet
your answer here had to do with stress
which made me think okay well why did
the iron versus efficiency versus
control show this thing
oh yeah
um
but
yeah i see what you're saying so um
i think there's well i guess i think
there's kind of a gradient of age so i
think one thing we did see and it's
again it's actually not as significant
as i thought but it's slightly enriched
in your grass-specific genes
you know what's going on in your iron
deficiency versus not
it's definitely not enriched and you
know angiosperm
everybody has it
and so i think that
it's slightly newer copies but maybe
maybe lots of species had to deal with
some metal stress in general but sort of
the more recent sorghum diversification
where we moved it around rapidly to lots
of places
those are the even newer genes
where you maybe you see changes
but i think what you bring up is a
really good question it certainly would
be worth looking it'd be nice to look at
some expression data
um
and just see
possibly if you can take public data
how many how many types of studies would
you see enrichment in a particular sort
of phylogenetic category to see whether
or not you know it does seem like things
to do with
human selection versus stress selection
um that sort of thing
one question
do you want me to read it
i got it
oh it just says if you oh okay
so do you have information about metal
contents between the lines oh
no um
that is a very that's a very good
question and that is something i just
put in a proposal
to try and look at because that's
something that we definitely want to
know you know rather than just looking
at the activity of the transporters is
do you actually see a difference in
you know who actually has a bunch of
iron in them or not if hypothetically
you think one is better at uptaking it
but it's not something that we have
seen yet
yeah i think early in your talk you
mentioned that a lot of the different
differentially expressed genes were in
response to pathogens maybe um i'm
wondering if if the vet one could fit
into this scenario just because um in
rice
um
the bacteria that causes bacterial
blight activates a sweet um in order to
fuel itself but there's a paper
a while back that showed that the copd
transporters for copper
can actually bind to this suite and
reduce pathogen spread so i'm just
wondering if there might be some sort of
shared molecular mechanism here of like
you know creating
uh reactive oxygen species or something
like yeah i think it's a i think it's a
really good point and i think it's
definitely um
it's definitely possible um you know and
that it's that what's actually going on
you know even though it can move iron
that maybe that's not its primary
function or not its primary role in
terms of what would make it make the
types
different and i you know i completely
agree that i think it it could be
something to do with you know
communicating you know either signaling
or like you say sort of pathogen
pathogen response um
certainly metals play all kinds of roles
in that and then even you know as
like miguel and i talked about things
that are called metal transporters don't
have to only transport metal and so
but then if i start thinking about that
i might just kind of despair as to what
we could ever that's what we could ever
figure out so
yes
uh good question so so clearly there's
huge differences in sorghum between
in the amount of sugar that can stay in
stem is this a general thing in grasses
like within a genus or within a species
of variation in sugar or maybe starch
content or just like
sorghum and or maybe you know i don't
know
so i think you know i mean you know they
have sort of maze lines that can also
accumulate sugar i i can i suspect
there's probably mechanisms
in grasses where it's possible
to at least evolve this or there's
there's some underlying machinery that
can get selected on and that's happened
multiple times and that's why you can
see it in sugarcane
see it in sorghum and see it and see it
in maize but um
you know what the
in terms of like which what we've
actually selected for to accumulate
sugar i don't know if those
variants were kind of in like an older
ancestor or if it's just the machinery
and then you've got a highly duplicated
region or a complex region where it's
easier to get new
structural variants and then do this
again and that's why you would see it
but one thing i you know one thing i
will say i kind of mentioned is that it
at least between sugarcane and sorghum
the actual mechanism looks different you
know we the first thing people did was
try and look at the super synthase
it's just not i mean like i say you can
see different expression but if you try
and look
at different lines the different types
are just doing totally different you
know it's just all over the place
so there's no it's not really
fundamentally underlying it
so like rice is there sweet stem rice
and and
i don't know anything i don't think not
that i know about not in a way where
it's ever been sort of
commercially produced to do anything
like a biofuel or a syrup
um
but there might be something
someone might have like a rice syrup
somewhere that i don't know about but i
don't think so
so and for those when they do the
alcohols i know it comes from the the
grain which sorghum the sorghum alcohol
sometimes they do it from the grain but
you can do it from the stem sugar as
well
a